So now we have modified our application times two.
We can check that off, and we have one last thing to do.
We're going to add a new feature.
Now before we move on, go ahead and
check in your changes if you're using version control.
That way, you can start right here before you do any of this stuff.
That's particularly important because this challenge is going to
be a little bit more difficult than the modification challenges.
Our new feature is going to be a priority button.
So now there will be a little exclamation mark button for
each one of these elements.
When you click on it, the task will be highlighted in red so
you remember to prioritize it over the others.
Unless it's checked off, in which case it won't be read at all.
Now once again, the CSS has been done for you.
When you add the priority button, give it a class of priority-BTN.
When a task is marked as prioritized, the LI should get a class of priority.
Now just so you remember that,
I'm putting that information down in the instructor notes.
Now, once again, I'll remind you to be a detective first.
Look around for
similar functionality, and see where it's implemented if you can.
And if you find something you're curious about, pull up the documentation for
Backbone.js, or do a Google search to try and figure out what's going on.
Go ahead and implement that priority button, and good luck.